la question est toujours très difficile
si vous voulez de caractériser une
imputabilité c'est à dire une cause d'un
médicament à un effet secondaire en
dehors des essais qui ont abouti à leur
mise sur le marché c'est le travail de
la pharmacologie vigilance et il ya
plusieurs techniques veut peut-être en
parlais tout à l'heure il ya plusieurs
techniques scientifiques qui permettent
si vous voulez de définir une lien de
cause c'est à dire le médicament là nous
a sauvé un médicament à un effet c'est à
dire le développement d'un effet qui
n'est pas à ce moment là un effet
indésirable mais est ce qu'on appelle un
effet secondaire c'est à dire qu'il est
qu'il est dû à ce médicament alors les
techniques il y en a il ya deux grands
types de techniques c'est si vous voulez
de comparer une population de patients
qui ont reçu le médicament à une
population qu'on appelle une population
témoin de patients qui n'ont pas reçu le
médicament et voir s'il ya un effet qui
est apparaît de manière plus fréquente
ma population kate qui a reçu le
médicament par rapport à l'autre la
deuxième technique pour finir c'est une
technique d'imputabilité c'est à dire
c'est le rôle des des scientifiques qui
sont dans la pharmacovigilance c'est à
dire qu'à partir d'un effet indésirable
qui a été détecté après l'administration
des médicaments ils vont faire une
enquête une enquête une véritable
enquête policière pour voir s'il ya des
raisons de penser que ce médicament est
la cause de cet effet indésirable pour
ce vaccin
en contre kovy 19 il ya eu un certain
nombre d'effets secondaires qui ont été
qui ont été déterminés qui ont une
fréquence assez faibles on se souvient
avec l'astra zeneca du risque
thromboembolique à et qui est irréelle
quelqu'un qui est un peu plus que la
normale et des effets des myocardite
aider péricardite qui sont parle aussi
de paralysie mais temporaire certains
n'ont alors rien il a parlé de sa scène
qui a été évoquée à un moment donné la
partie faciale périphériques et c'est ça
qui est transitoire en fait non en fait
non il ya plusieurs études qui ont
montré que dans la population témoin y
avait pas plus de paralysie faciale que
dans la population vaccinée c'est un
article qui date déjà de quelques mois
dans le new england ken la revue de
référence est qui et qui a rejeté cette
hypothèse d'accord louis villaret
professeur - ya quelque chose qui
m'étonne quand on regarde les
publications scientifiques je regardais
en france ou dans le monde anglo saxon
on nous dit assez peu comme vous le
révéler d'effets secondaires quand on
regarde les réseaux sociaux de ces mêmes
pays on voit plein de gens qui
témoignent d'effets secondaires donc moi
ma question aller simple est ce que la
littérature scientifique est ce que les
médecins ne nous manque pas alors parce
que il ya une confusion je suis aussi
dans les réseaux sociaux et je vois une
confusion extrême important entre effets
secondaires et effets indésirables je
veux dire que quand vous prenez un
médicament donc soit veuf c'est autre
chose la vie ne s'arrête pas et les
risques de la vie ne s'arrête pas c'est
à dire vous pouvez développer des
maladies avoir des accidents
mais même décédé ce qui est important de
savoir c'est si vous avez ce médicament
si ce risque augmente donc cet objet de
comparer et ce que je vois dans le
réseau sociaux c'est évidemment un seul
groupe le groupe qui a reçu le
médicament et qui dès lors qu'ils ont un
accident de vie l'imputé c'est normal
c'est normal parce que quand un accident
dans la vie on sait qu'on sait que c'est
injuste merci et et quand c'est injuste
on cherche un coupable évidemment en
fait ce rapprochement et je veux dire je
le respecte ce rapprochement